[Musik]
doch wenn man mir das zimmer vom einzige
sohn björn sieber zahn xi und mein sohn
ist eine verstorbene schafft noch mehr
als drei jahre das zimmer umstellen und
[Musik]
spürt dass ich jetzt die kraft und das
spürt dass ich ganz viel glücksgefühl
auch jetzt zum ruhme und wie oft man ist
das ausleitung koma wieder lebensmut und
freude werden
davon handelt diese reportage
[Musik]
im
pin und mobile und kannte ich persönlich
sie lebten ganz in meiner nähe
geblieben ist mir vor allem seine
nachdenkliche art diese gar nicht zu
einem teenager passen wollte
für ihn war 17 als er starb es geschah
vor drei jahren
der berner dem artikel ab die hand gegen
admira mexikanisch kochen
es ist ein wunderbarer nabi ziehen
ich hatte mir nach geschick mit dem
druck
und was ist das ist wie im film das so
in meine gedanken ist so ihm im herzen
dass wir dich bisher nicht an die werte
in ihren tragen
in dieser summe noch die so fröhlich
begonnen hatte starb er in seinem bett
er war epileptiker aber die todesursache
konnte nie mit absoluter sicherheit
festgestellt werden
vielleicht war es ein epileptischer
anfall vielleicht ein herzversagen
wenn ich so tief gehend ruhig dass man
gar nichts gefühlt es schien der genannt
wird emotionen nach allgemein mit einem
mal lachen und man wird sich das via
unterzahl beginnen oder zurück gestellt
dass und das wird auf und hört ja ihre
trauer scheint mir noch nicht ganz
verflogen zu sein
durch sie kämpft hartnäckig und findet
so nach und nach zurück zu sich selber
stefan büsser ist so etwas wie ein
geborener spaß mache
[Applaus]
seine kollegen können im braven zählen
wenn es etwas zu feiern gibt aber
niemand würde dem 28-jährigen anmerken
dass der an einer unheilbaren krankheit
leidet regelmäßige arztbesuche gehören
zusteht von düster sonntag
seit geburt hat das system fibrose dabei
bildet sich in der loonie zäher schleim
der das organ mit den jahren stetig wir
haben jetzt gemessen eine sekunde
kapazitäts von 1,8 liter das entspricht
32 prozent 32 von 100% lungenkapazität
ein grund um sich sorgen zu machen
nicht so für stefan gute werbung gerade
vor mallorca kommen also wahrscheinlich
gut dass wir sind stabil und das obwohl
jetzt zwei wochen erhältlich als kam für
kochen steht von begegnet seinem leiden
mit viel optimismus
wer seine krankheit annehme sei weniger
gestresst sagt der arzt christian
beenden
allerdings müsse jemand der cystische
fibrose hat mit einer geringeren
lebenserwartung rechnen
wenn heute ein kind geboren wird dann
würden wir davon ausgehen dass die
mittlere lebenserwartung über 40 jahre
liegt aufgrund der tatsache dass die der
symptomatische therapie sich in den
letzten jahren deutlich verbessert hat
den eltern corina und konrad bücher
wurde nach der geburt ihres sohnes wenig
hoffnung gemacht
die ganze sportwelt gazastreifen
12 das glaubt dass der pubertät und das
ja jetzt sind noch immer lang als
familie geburtstag vor die irische ganz
schwierig da wieder einer weniger und
das ist heute führend wenn es dafür in
den letzten tagen habe ich mit vielen
bekannten genießt es wird es ziemlich
beschäftigt hat das will sich nämlich
mit dem auto vorbei und sie mir am 2
und am friedhof für den fahrer
unterstützen unterschied zwischen
erwachsenen grad
das ist so
das ist einfach so er habe sich heute
mit seinem schicksal versöhnt sagt mir
stefan noch an diesem abend aber das war
nicht immer so
das ist gut so in der pubertät
eigentlich zu jung sagt ein freund
irgendwie sowie und angeboten
aber irgendwann schließt man mit der
frage ob will also es geht ja auch keine
antwort ob sie das wünschen wir dass ihn
jemand anderes als die schöne aber die
frage stellt wie sie implizieren damit
ja aber auch dass es andere gibt was
wahrscheinlich mehr für die enten aber
das wünscht man ja keinem
kilian beherrscht ihren körper immer
weniger
der grund multiple sklerose diese
unheilbare erkrankung des zentralen
nervensystems begann vor rund 20 jahren
nach der geburt ihrer tochter
trotz ihrer behinderung nimmt die
48-jährige hausfrau aktiv am leben teil
wenn man das wort stadtlauf vorhand sams
kühlmorgen früher und jobs hoffen die
gesamte gar nicht was dahinter ist
günstiger mit wirklichem yaman
geschnitten so hohe tatra
ich muss ja gleich eine vita lappen und
ich an mentalität
ich nehme das vielleicht nicht so
tragisch
ich war aber wiederum und mache es feste
dominiert dank festnahme sowie kommt
jede wirkung ihre mutter portland
schweizer unterstützt barbara bei jeder
gelegenheit frisch aus usd aufwenden
ja du ich kann einfach nicht aufhören
bis magische schnarcher so schlampig
nehmen und ich bin ein niveau ja halt
gerne bis macht und unternehmt und
beschädigung stopp liegt aber ist
vernarrt in ihre pferde mit delta ist
sie oft aus gerichten bis zu jenem
verhängnisvollen tag vor drei monaten
was ist denn passiert ja ich bin damit
dass taylor bean ihrem lauf xi zwischen
velofahrer
im angefahren und ist erschrocken da
hätte ich mich natürlich aber krüer toni
dass sie etwa lehrern praktisch alles
auf die rechte sie zerbrochen und der
halbblut ik und termine krankheit gott
hat das haus immer noch länger trotz des
unfalls hat barbara ein ziel verfolgen
wieder zu reiten das gefühl wenn beruf
geht der machthaber kombi land erlebe
ich heute anders als vor dem tod ihres
sohnes
ich erinnere mich an unsere erste
begegnung
es war vor vier jahren bayern war für
über den ich eine reportage machte mit
dabei war auch sohn jürgen
sie wanderte damals oft mit dem leben
wieso geht es ihm um den bedarf aus ohne
gewalt und ohne tische und eben im
ständig und ewig für alles kämpfen
ihr wahlkampf begann aber erst nach wir
uns tot
yvonne verlor jeden lebensmut und wollte
nur noch eines sterben die dunklen
gedanken begleiteten sie monatelang dann
aber auf der sie sich auf sie versuchte
es mit einer maltherapie einem trauer
seminar und anderen therapeutischen
angeboten mich ansprach und ich bin da
bilde sind völlig aus das ist definitiv
eine emanzipierte mir selber gefunden
glaube es qualität findet ganz kleine
sache und das ist wahnsinn geschafft und
die hufe ihnen nach hause und da dankbar
sie ist die schlimmste sache
wertschätzen und das ist natur das sind
manche dass ich das was ich dann meinen
ja wieder gut geht das ist das wo mich
glücklich macht wo wir sehen gibt ich
habe den sinn
dauernde fröhlichkeit gehört zum beruf
und stellt von düster als radiomoderator
hat der junge mann seinen traumberuf
gefunden
[Musik]
kurz war johann praktisch unbekannt
herr wüst lottoscheine konnte sich heute
als oberflächliches medium postens zu
ihnen passt das zu wenig macht
wahnsinnig gern was ist schnell dass ich
so was sich direkt wieder los aber ja
großmann hat jetzt nicht für die
wahnsinnig tiefgründige gespräche und
sieht da war nur irgendwo erhalten
nutzer zur verfügung haben stefan lebt
am stadtrand von zürich und ist single
eine familie werde wohl kaum je haben
verrät er mir seine kinder müssten ja
damit rechnen ohne ihren vater
aufzuwachsen
über die zukunft versucht er sich
möglichst wenig sorgen zu machen
ich will aber dass man fertig ist hat ja
alles gebraucht und ja auch eine und das
könnte im moment ist das grundlegende
gedanken krankheit wo sieht wäre
überzüge braucht hat tradition die
stelle koma und aber das grundvertrauen
katholischen sicher die gedanken der
morgenfrühe müssen stellen und
nebenprojekte was gutmachen und so jeden
tag machen dann kann ich noch nie
gesehen hat aber so einfach im grundsatz
richtig
auf jeden fall die krankheit multiple
sklerose und die folgen des unfalls
binden barbara kilian teilweise an den
rollstuhl wegen der medikamente die sie
nehmen muss hat ja auch noch
knochenschwund grund umfragen hätte sie
also genug
[Musik]
klar geht es mir nicht gut gott wovon
lachen bringen und und irgendwie mit
europa schenker kopf wieso das habe ich
hier und da aber wenn ich dann mal
wieder merke es gott wirklich nur was
wirklich die junge dass maria und martha
test so schlachter gott sein und daran
ja mit brauche dann bin ich lieber der
fröhlich mensch und gott als lawinen
erzieher mit minen familien mit kind
mehr glück das ist jemand rose kilian
und sabrina barm raster aus erster ehe
heute trifft sich die patchworkfamilie
sie halten zusammen und helfen sich sohn
damian hat die gelernte grafisch
stefania mitgebracht
dabei weiß ich wirklich froh dass es so
hart zu mir stand weiland liegt wo ihr
eigenes gebrachte hand die hand nicht
dass seine familie wie niveau zu einem
stand und mit ihm auch alles sondern
ahmet und schaue mich wenn die man
gesagt wie komisch laufe wenn es mir mal
an inter so wahnsinnig gut gott der dich
immer wieder zum lachen bringen dass er
meine streben der schritt über grenzen
und das ist da so im realen unterstützt
zu werden denn somit sechs der musterung
und so ergibt sich ein paradox das
schicksal von debra hat die familie
zusammengeschweißt
hoch oben in den bergen steht ein
ehemaliger stall der zu einer kleinen
oase umgebaut wird
nicht zuletzt wegen der renovation von
yvonne und ihr lebenspartner guido meyer
einen weg zurück ins leben
die beschäftigung mit dem umbau auf den
beiden die depressionen nach münster zu
vertreiben
ich finde mir wirklich sehr sehr gut
gefunden haben sind schon nicht so
wirklich will intensivster jedes wochen
am vorstand ist wie man das stück nicht
pro mensch wirtschaft mobil und führt
eine praxis für rücken und gelenke
therapien
sie sagt das eigene schicksal habe sie
zu einer besseren therapeutin gemacht
für mich ist es wunderbar streep mit dem
was ich selber erfahrung mit der
mannschaft versteht was sie mir wand
sage und tue es leid dass sie trug sie
wieder die lebendigkeit zu erfahren dass
mit körperbetontem ich gute gespräche
begleitet von mir die schritt der
verkauf
stefan büsser tanzt auf vielen bühnen
der radiomoderator tritt auch als
komiker auf und kennt dabei keine
schmerzgrenze
sein programm entstand während deines
spitalaufenthalte und ist erstmals
stärkste zum ihrer und sie lobt sie dass
ich jetzt bin ich dachte oh geil das
wasser sauber hoch ist das auch etwas
mit der wortwahl im spital
so zum beispiel rekord der kunde steht
seit jahren haben ihr kraft und
spielerische allgemein vieles nicht so
wie sie eigentlich heißt also die
krankenschwester so krank sind und damit
den untergrund maschinen die kiste
ortsmitte meinen doktor sondern hat nur
für die bürgerlichen mit 28 ist er auf
dem sprung landesweit bekannt zu werden
stefan hat trotz schwere krankheit ein
rezept gefunden sein leben zu genießen
ein großteil ich gehe das ich so liebe
wahrscheinlich ein charakterzug das
haben wir aber hat man dann kommt dazu
dass ich einen beruf der woche wo mini
liegenschaft ich und ich wirklich jeden
tag freude haben in europa die amok seid
also wenn ich eine pause machen was ich
mache
dann wird es mir wahrscheinlich
schlechter und das ist schon sehr
entscheidend dass das man macht wollen
wir jeden tag macht haben mit viel
freude machen
das ist sicher das hilft für positive
aber sie stellt
heute ist ein wichtiger tag für barbara
kilian nur träumen obwohl sie vor drei
monaten vom pferd fiel und sich dabei
schwer verletzte will sie mit hilfe
eines kollegen wieder ausweiten
nach dem umfall als auch die natürlich
schon immer ganz normales risiko sieg
und was ist riskant würde ich mich in
frage
im ganzen aber irgendwo das kannte ich
habe ich finde man muss einfach nur
alles tot
der direkte und das ist vielleicht die
moral dieser geschichte
wer nach einem rückschlag wieder
aufsteigt beiden von oben
[Musik]
jedes mal wenn ich da drauf
das macht ja nicht wie gedacht